I'm Mark Stewart I am a musician a
performer and an instrument designer and
you're in my house in Park Slope
I am entranced and intrigued by sound
and sound makers whether it's a found
object or whether it's a created musical
instrument and so I've surrounded myself
with sound makers and the materials to
make them these are all destined to be
harps but they're also destined to be
ears on the side of these big musical
faces that I've made I've been making
for a wonderful work conceived by the
brilliant composer of palo pristine e
the aging magician and like any workshop
that's been used over time the
accumulation has to do with all the
different projects and then the hope
that that that springs eternal inside
the craftsmen's heart that that future
projects will I want to use these ten
ears I want I want these all to be these
crazy microtonal harps that anyone can
play and I know that they will be
this has been dubbed the lab annex
this room the lab annex the lab was my
old three-bedroom Apartments and the
lower Eastside it was this times five
he was absolutely packed and there were
some times where all there was was a
path it looked a little bit like those
pictures you see of hoarders places
except everything in the place was a
musical instrument so a lot of things
aren't here obviously but the things
that are here are here and I'll give you
a little tour here are some conch
trumpets some old tuba mouthpieces that
get thrown on to this beast over here
it's very lightweight but it plays in
the tuba range and it's from the end of
the 19th century this is I guess you
could say it's the pocket didgeridoo all
manner of bamboos a foon's the wonderful
instruments from Maui made by Brian
Whitman beautiful old parlour guitars
and there's my idea for for how to bring
it back to life
these are wonderful wooden nose flutes
this is a plectrum guitar
Martin made six or seven of these it was
an experiment and it didn't work out was
in the early 30s and the plectrum guitar
was an instrument that came and went
they thought maybe it was going to be
the next big thing and it wasn't so but
it's a big thing here in this room the
best music stores are always ones that
have been there forever and just have a
lot of room full of junk you know room
full of castoffs things that I'm this
room is a little bit like the you know
the Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer the
island of misfit toys there is a little
bit of element of the misfits you know
in this room certainly
when I'm on an airplane and I'm carrying
a musical instrument to spy I'm often
SOR you a musician and I said yes I am
and they say well what kind of music do
you play
and I say well I play a little bit of
popular music quite a bit of semi
popular music an enormous amount of
unpopulated
and their question is usually well what
son popular music and I say all the
music you haven't heard of and then we
have this wonderful conversation about
contemporary music and improvised music
and and the music that I encourage
people to play with the instruments I
make and and then gradually we get to
the semi popular and the popular the
popular music fellow I play with most
frequently is Paul Simon and I am now
considered the MD the music director for
for Paul which just means when he's not
in the room I'm the only beta and a band
full of alphas and so they'll all listen
to me and so he gets stuff done with
Paul I play anything he asked me to
essentially I play guitar and cello and
mandolin and banjo and and the fune so
that's the little pocket sax that's my
constant companion so that gets played
that beautiful moment in the boxer the
semi popular music I I play is largely
with the group bang on a can bang in a
can is a is an organization that began
in 1987 and it's a commissioning
organization and a presenting
organization and there's also a house
band dynamic and all-stars
when people ask me what would your
what's your favorite music what's your
favorite piece what's your favorite
instrument what's your favorite kind of
thing to do in your profession I I can't
answer that for me it's the variety that
is that is my favorite